oh who believe fear Allah as he should
be feared and do not die except that you
are
Muslims submitting to the to the will of
Allah oh oh mankind for your God your
lord who created you from a single soul
and from that Soul he created his M and
from them came many men and women so
fear Allah from whom you demand your
Mutual rights and keep the ties of
kinship you believe
Allah and say a word directed to the
truth a good word directed to to the
truth that Allah
May Rectify your actions and forgive
your sins for indeed whoever obeys Allah
and his messenger has attained a great
success the best speech is the book of
Allah there's no one better in speech
than Allah and who is better in speech
than
Allah the best speech is the speech of
Allah the Quran
the best speech Perfection from which
any whichever angle you look at the
Quran perfection in the letters in the
words in the stories in the
parables in the description of the pre
what transpired with the previous
prophets and Messengers what will
transpire for the people heading into
paradise and those going to the Hellfire
perfection in the story in the call and
in the message
Perfection and the best
Guidance the best guidance is that
of
wasallam and the worst of the Affairs
are the newly invented matters that
people invent in the
religion for every innovation for every
newly invented matter is an innovation
and every innovation in the religion is
a misguidance and every misguidance
leads to the
fire what a beautiful topic to go over
this evening we thank our brothers in
M for this invitation we ask Allah to
forgive us our shortcomings and may
Allah make this approv for us not
against us on the day of judgment what a
beautiful topic the statement of IM
from the scholars of
sh upon you is to hold on to the ntion
of the Sal even if the people were to
were to abandon you the narrations of
the Sala who are the salf the salf the
righteous predecessors the Messenger s
wasallam said to his
daughter what a blessed predecessor I am
to you so he used the word Sal the word
Sal means predecessor the one who came
before and the messenger already said
that the best of people are the first
three
generations the best people in my
generation then them to come after them
then them to come after them there the
best Generations the best people I mean
and they're the
sahaba and their students and their
students
and by the way is
in he said when it was said to him
there's a group of who deny that the
Believers will see Allah on the day of
judgment and also they deny they deny
that Allah descends to the lowest
Heavens in the last third part of the
night every
night so sh from the scholars of
the as for us
then we take our
de we take our Dean from the sons of the
companions from the companions where do
they take their Dean from and we say
this to all the
groups all the groups and all the
callers
we take our de the the methodology the
the worship we take it from the sons of
the companions from the companions where
do they take it from and the companions
take it from who they take it from
the and the companion are they're the
trustworthy
ones this knowledge will be carried by
the the the trustworthy ones of of every
generation the of every
generation who follow the way of the the
best of people of the of Muhammad s alhi
wasallam they will expel the distortions
of the
extremists and the destructions of those
who try to destroy what
and the false interpretations of the
ignorant they will expel all that
because they will
carry and they will expel and how
Innovations and
desires so what we have before us my
dear brothers and sisters ERS what we
have before us are statements of the
because the of
the
as is reported from
and that he
said that economizing upon the path and
the Sunnah is better than
striving upon opposition to the path and
the Sunnah you see innovators you find
them striving
upon what
upon this statement is simar to who said
the
same you strive upon the you economize
upon the Sunnah few sunnas that you do
is better than the many Bas that others
do and this is in line with
the the most beloved actions towards
Allah are those that are continuous even
though they are few so abdah you have
chance
you have a great chance you be sincere
and you do actions according to the
Sunnah even if there are few you have
great chance you will
surpass the many that upon the upon the
[Applause]
Innovations so you look at your actions
whether it is many actions that you put
forward or a few actions that you put
forward that it is upon the methodology
of the prophets and their path may Allah
subh be upon them from the narration
of said I heard my
grandmother she
said two men entered upon
muham the great
scholar from
the so these two men came from the from
the people of
desires his was
abak we'll give you aith we tell you
a we will not he said
no recite to you a verse from the book
of
Allah you leave me both of you or I will
get up and go so either you get up and
go or I get up and go and this
narration mentions it in his likewise
mentions it in
his number
two42
Im whom we mentioned at the beginning
who
said also he himself
said do not allow the people of
innovation do not allow them yeah do not
be in a position where you're arguing
with them such that they pierce or place
in your hearts a f f of doubts F of sh F
of is a
sh keep away from those disputes with
those who may place in your
heart as it was said to IM
Malik one of the innovators said to him
I will
debates with
you and if and if I win you follow me
and if you win I follow you so IM Malik
said to him what if a third person comes
and he defeats both of us in his
arguments so the man person of how
person of desires he said if he defeats
both of us then we both follow
him so imik said go I'm not in doubt of
my Dean I'm not in doubt
of my so you are in doubt so you go to
somebody like yourself who's in
doubt this is how the people of deal
with the people Innovation and the
people of desires that they are not in
doubt because why we take out Dean from
the sons of the companions from The
Companions and where do they take their
de
from wasallam and is the chain of
narration going back toam taking
the the authentic narration
said if it had hadn't been for isad the
change of
narration being authentic going back to
the messenger wasallam anyone will say
what he likes anyone will say what he
likes
and
161d was 110
161 from the scholars of the what did he
say beautiful
statement great
scholar they say he he memorized
thousand
thousand he
said he
said the is the weapon of the
believer if he doesn't have the isnad
how can he fight how can he protect the
dean defend the dean how can he clarify
if he doesn't know authentic narrations
from those that are not authentic how
can he clarify he would not be able to
and that's why
the of they
are if they are
not then who else are they the people of
Hadith as it was said in the sitting of
Imam
ah and some some of the scholars
mentioned in the sitting
of it was said in their
City upon you is to follow and his
people because opinion is like nights
unclear while is clear like day time
it may be a youth can't see the path of
guidance while the sun is shining in its
Splendor the sun is shining and you
can't see who the are how you don't know
the it's clear the path
of is clear in every generation because
the messenger wasallam said he
said they will not cease to be a group
upholding the truth from my um
clearly upon the
truth they will not be harm by those who
abandon them nor by those who oppose
them until the command of Allah comes
while they upon that they will not be
harmed by those who abandon them nor by
those who differ or oppose from them
until the command of Allah comes not
harmed are not harmed by the
he used to say in some of his lectures
or lessons he used to say and he
mentioned this also in his defense
of in his famous
book he
said huh the the the clouds will not be
harmed by the barking of dogs cuz the
Barking of dogs is not going to harm the
cloud is it and likewise those
innovators who speak against in every
generation they only harm
themselves as is as the well-known
saying oh one who wants to head back the
mountain have mercy on your head head
not on the mountain because the mountain
is strong the mountain is firm like the
is strong and is firm and he clarifies
the Sunnah and he
clarifies because the they the ones who
clarify andah they clarify the path to
Jen and they show us the severity of the
Hellfire they show us the severity of sh
the severity of B thereafter then the
severity of sins yes sins are
destructive but worse than sins
it doesn't mean that we have toah of
sins that we are neglectful of sins sins
are
destructive so be careful of sinning
Allah this is referring to those who
went against
prophet and they pierced and they killed
the shiku you see the shiku was a test
for the people they were this she Cel
was not like any other she C it was a
large
enormous she C and it was drinking from
the
river and it there the people were told
you have one day for you to drink from
the river and leave the other day for
the sh the people they fed they fed for
themselves that water will end and they
did not listen
to the prophet to
prophet and also they ended up conniving
amongst themselves and they killed the
she Cel they killed
it and Allah straight away look and this
shows you that the punishment of sins
can can come straight
away don't think that you do a sin and
the punishment can't come straight away
the punishment can come straight away
afterwards because after after they
after Allah
mentions straight away the punishment
came that's why we can't be Luxy Daisy
with sins we can't be Luxy Daisy with
sins we have to fear falling into sins
they are destructive and they could harm
and of course B is worse than sin
because a person may repent from his sin
but not necessarily from his b because
he thinks he's doing good we can't be
neglectful of of having to how thinking
that sins Halas doesn't matter we're in
Paradise we're in Jen we've made it none
of us have made it we still have a long
way to go we still have to pass the test
in the grave we still have to live this
life and the Soul has to live we still
have to die upon before that and
thereafter we still have to pass the
punishment of the
Grave cuz some people will be punish
because of sins the person who back
bites the person who tail carries this
punishment in the of the gra of the
Grave due to that the
messenger he passed by two graves and he
said they are been punished both of
them they have not they not been
punished due to a major sin then he
paused and he received
Revelation rather is it's a major sin is
due to a major
sin as for one of them he used to tail
carry amongst the
people he used to backbite between the
people and that's for the other one he
never used to conceal
himself when whilst urinating while he
going to the bathroom you should use
tissue with water
use water cons clean yourself because it
could have two meanings the the urine
went on your all over your body and the
second meaning is the UR you did not
conceal yourself from the eyes of the
people whilst
urinating and those two meanings
mentioned by in his explanation of so
coning oneself from urine and also
concealing onel whil urine urin the
person must be careful there's a
punishment of the Grave so we have to
pass that and we haven't reached that
yet may Allah protect us from the
punishment of the grave and thereafter
the resurrection people sorted out into
groups we haven't got there yet and then
thereafter the people will get their
book of Reckoning whether it's going to
be
or we haven't got that yet we haven't
reached that yet and therea we're going
to have to be weighed you will be
weighed your Scrolls will be weighed and
likewise
your actions will be weighed we still
haven't reached that and we still
thereafter also we have to pass the that
has hooks grabbing the people throwing
them into the
Hellfire all that we haven't done and
even after all of that if you have
wronged somebody you will not enter J
until the wrong that you have wronged
somebody with a that you have done will
be will be returned to that person that
you have wronged you won't be able to
enter Jenner until that wrong is H is
sorted out so therefore so therefore my
dear brothers and sisters and Elders the
reality is is close you may see it as
far
away they see it as far away you may see
it as far away Allah
says but it's close it's coming everyone
is going to meet his Reckoning everyone
has an a a lifespan so he has to live a
life of narrations a life of returning
to the book of Allah and the of the
messeng wasallam and with that there is
salvation as for being mishmash all over
the place
cocktail one day one foot one day with
this one and one foot with that one that
is not
is the one that goes toppled on his face
is he guided more guided than the one
who is upon no they are not the
[Music]
same they're not equal the the the
distasteful things the evil things the
filthy things and the good things they
don't equal even though most people go
towards the evil things most people go
go towards the evil things and as well
the one who knows and the one who
doesn't
know they're not
[Music]
equal the one who knows and the one who
don't they're not equal so therefore my
dear brothers and sisters we have to go
back to the original State of Affairs as
said nothing will rectify the last part
of this um except that which retif
the first part
and who we started with which is the
title of this conference that is the
great scholar of sham he
said not
just going to have to be patient it's
not easy the path requires
patience so you have to make your soul
patient restrict your soul away from
desires
make your soul patient upon the
Sunnah and stop where the sahaba stopped
because here means people the who's the
people that he's referring to the sahab
stop where the sah
stopped and say with that which they
said and withhold from what they
withheld from
and hold on to the path of the pious
predecessors for what was sufficient for
them should be sufficient for you and
that is